You could ask one question
I'd like,
I'd like to ask them how the hell he
figured out what it figured out because I
can't,
I can understand how he can call
incalculably intelligent.
You know,
when I read,
I read everything he wrote the
1990s but 25 volumes of stuff.
It wasn't like I understood all
of it cause it's tough going.
I've just never been able to figure
out how he can figure out what he did.
Maybe at an Iq of 180 you know,
people do one in a billion,
you know,
maybe he was wanting to billion so he
could see things that I can't figure out
how anyone can see.
But you know,
it might just be an
incredible intelligence.
He sees to have a gift for imagination.
Like,
you know,
some people are very good at articulation
and we're good at thinking in words
and some people are good at thinking in
pictures and he seemed to be really good
at both.
You know,
I had a tremendous amount of sedation
and could dream 12 weight essentially.
And to learn how to do that and seem
to learn all sorts of things from his
weekend dreams.
You know,
and I can do that a little bit.
sometimes when I'm doing
therapy with people,
for example,
I'll be listening to the macro picture
will pop into my head there a little
fragment of the story,
you know,
like a dream.
It comes with imagery and it
sort of didn't background.
And then I'll notice it and
then I'll tell the person,
they said,
look,
when you said that this
happened in my imagination,
we can take apart the relationship between
what they said and what happened in
my imagination.
And that usually shipped substantial
light on what's going on.
But he was an absolute master at that.
So I do actually find out
from him how he managed that.
And maybe you couldn't say,
but I actually like to know that.
Anyone like that.
So there were a couple of questions.